what's going on guys this is rob and
this isn't really a theory video so much
is just kind of like a curiosity video
because i'm i'm curious to see
whether or not we're gonna get the sky
fathers
in thor love and thunder because we know
that like or at least the rumors are
saying anyway and as far as i'm aware i
think it's been confirmed that russell
crowe is playing zeus in that movie
which makes sense russell crowe is the
perfect guy to play the role of zeus i
mean he just looks the part
i don't know if that's true or not i'm
not gonna swear by it uh but supposedly
zeus is going to appear in the movie and
that kind of got me thinking right the
idea of the sky fathers because what's
going on in the marvel cinematic
universe especially with like looking at
moon knight is they're doing a lot of
exploration of like the godly pantheons
and there's a lot of cool stuff to be
had there but before we get into that we
do need to thank our sponsor for this
video atlas vpn so for those of you guys
who do not know right now at this moment
and this is an absolutely insane deal
atlas vpn is running this massive
discount right it means you can get like
a three-year subscription for just a
buck 99 a month for two bucks a month
and they've got like a 30-day money-back
guarantee it's
insane you don't need to know much about
vpns to know that's an insane deal so
for those of you guys who don't know
what a vpn is this means virtual private
network and what it means is that when
you have atlas vpn activated on your
devices your laptop or your desktop or
your phone your internet traffic is
funneled through essentially an
encrypted tunnel meaning no one can
really see what you're actually doing so
it can protect you from like spying
public wi-fi issues and it hides your ip
address and your online activities now
one of the huge benefits of having a vpn
is the issue of geo restriction for
those guys who don't know what that
means sometimes streaming services will
have programming setup which is only
available in certain regions so if
you're in the united states
you may not be able to see programming
that's actually available on netflix in
canada but with atlas vpn you can
actually bypass all of that which
basically means that you can see content
on streaming services that is not
readily available to you so again right
now at this moment atlas vpn is running
this massive discount right it means you
can get like a three-year subscription
for two bucks a month with a 30-day
money-back guarantee so time's running
out make sure you get your deal by
clicking the link in the video
description below and with that being
said let's get back into our video so my
my first question here that i'm that i'm
really kind of asking is do you guys
think we'll see the sky fathers now for
those of you guys who don't know who
that is on earth you have what's called
the council of godheads or the council
elites or sky fathers they go by
different names depending on on who's
referencing them who's writing the comic
and even who's talking about them in the
comic itself uh but in essence on earth
you have all kinds of civilizations
right that have have that range from
those that have been around for
thousands and thousands of years to
those that have only been around for you
know a few hundred years and formed
their own belief systems right the
church of the flying spaghetti monster
so the thing about this
i like just randomly shouting things
that i know uh i feel like i'm gonna
start developing uh tourette's like i'm
just gonna give myself tourette syndrome
but uh but nonetheless right each one of
these cultures that exists out there
they have a god they worship now in
marvel comics the origins of those gods
sometimes mirror the origins of those
gods in the real world other times those
gods simply don't exist so like the
bashango people of central africa for
example believed in the great god bomba
who was basically the source of all
creation with regards to the the sun and
the moon and the stars and earth and
there was a lot of vomiting and so on
but he doesn't exist as part of the sky
fathers instead sometimes marvel will
take those different gods that exist as
part of the sky fathers that exist here
in the real world and they'll actually
change their origin and make them more
superheroey right to fit the the kind of
fictional comic book narrative that
we've largely come to expect but in
essence despite all these different gods
that exist as most of you guys know when
it comes to uh to these different
cultures you have like the head gods
right the chief gods so with the the
greek mythos for example it is zeus and
hera and the uh in the asgardian mythos
it is odin and freya and so that's
usually how that works now the council
of godheads is only ever really guys um
and so you have like the hindu god
vishnu different things like that they
don't really come together all the time
and in fact they don't really do much
there's only been a couple of times when
they were relevant well there's two
important times and one kind of
important time depending on how you look
at it so the first time when they were
incredibly relevant was when humanity
had basically started worshiping them as
gods due to these these individual
cultures own understanding of these
beings right however it is that they
happen to come into existence or however
it is these cultures became aware of
their existence but because of the fact
that the belief in these gods and the
power of these gods would basically or
could potentially disrupt the evolution
of humanity when the celestials came
back for the second and third hosts
really the third house more than
anything else they instructed the
council of godheads not to intervene not
to be involved in the affairs of mortal
men which is why in the history of
humanity and marvel comics you see
stories where like thor and odin and
these guys are routinely involved in the
affairs of humanity then suddenly it
stops it's because basically the
celestials told them to stop otherwise
they would be destroyed
the second time when they were
incredibly relevant
was really during the events of the
chaos war when amatsu mikabashi was just
racing through and killing every god he
could come across and even some of the
cosmic entities and doing it on a
multiversal level it was kind of nuts um
and then the the time when they were
kind of important but not really was
during infinity gauntlet when thanos had
the had like the gauntlet itself and
everything he was going to blink out
half the life of the universe the
council of godheads were going to
intervene but thanos actually separated
them from basically all creation from
the universe itself and so there was you
know having them cut off there was no
real way for them to gain access to uh
to really stop thanos and even if they
could have there wouldn't have been
anything they could have done uh but
nonetheless they've had different roles
now here's the reason why i say this is
a cool concept is because you have like
the iniad for example in moon knight
right so like amon raw and those guys
they're part of the council of godhead
it's really amun-ra is but like part of
the council of godheads it's not always
simply the leaders occasionally somebody
like horus or osiris will step in and
end up being the leader or at least have
a voice on the council of godheads and
the event that like almond raw can't do
it but regardless of the situation
there's a lot of expansion going on with
the godly the godly elements of the
marvel universe now the reason why i say
thor love and thunder is the best time
to introduce the council of godheads is
because of the nature of gore right that
gore i don't know exactly what form he's
going to take in the movie we won't
really know until the movie comes out if
he's just a guy who hates gods or
whatever it is he's almost an identical
version of his comic book counterpart or
if he's something else but in the comics
he hated gods because his people
suffered all the time they lived in a
really harsh environment he didn't
believe that gods existed until he
basically cursed the idea of gods he
essentially came out and told his tribe
that was highly religious that he didn't
believe in the idea of gods and they
essentially kicked him out this of
course was after like his wife and his
children died of just the harsh
environment they were in and all that
kind of stuff and then when he
discovered gods were real he came to the
realization gods don't care and so
that's when he was like then we'll just
get rid of god's and so ultimately he
went on this crusade across the universe
after stealing the all-black necro sword
of knoll and started killing gods
everywhere that he could find them
that's when you got a huge expansion of
things because up to that point the only
gods that we were aware of that existed
outside of earth were like klubben and
slugert so basically the gods of the
scroll empire um i know cigarette sounds
like a drink you know the sound you make
when you're drinking a slushie i know
it's it's weird you know a slugger but
uh nonetheless we knew they existed
right it was basically emerging of the
eternal scrolls and the deviant scrolls
in order to perform or create a kind of
unified society um there was shara and
ke3 who were the gods of the shia empire
there might be a few others up to that
point but not a ton i mean the supreme
intelligence was about as close as you
got to a god among the cree race uh
because it was basically all the
greatest minds that ever existed in the
korean empire combined into the supreme
intelligence so he was basically the
religious and political leader uh but
then you you got into like this
expansion with thor god of thunder by
jason aaron where it was like there were
gods of bombs and there were gods of
like peace and harmony like basically
god's on all these different worlds
across the universe and gore was killing
them all right like even like the
library of worlds right where you had
like all these gods that would convene
and meet and things along those lines so
it was a huge expansion of stuff and so
if gore is anything like his kind of a
counterpart of course we're likely going
to see that element the only real
question is how far-reaching does it go
and so i don't know if there would be
like a scene in the movie when thor is
like fi like when he's learning all
these gods are being killed or something
like that um and then he basically goes
to like the greek city of olympia and
finds that like zeus has basically been
attacked or zeus is in the middle of
attacking or fighting gore and then like
zeus dies or like hercules is there or
something along those lines um or
they've basically been killed and like
he's talking to russell crowe zeus and
it's like his last dying few breaths you
know gore the god butcher was the one
that did this to us i don't really see
them bringing in russell crowe to play
zeus to speak like five lines and then
die right to have like
a three-minute cameo um i don't really
see that happening
but uh but it's i guess this is entirely
possible but i don't know if that's
gonna be the case right or maybe like
like thor teams up with the greek gods
or what have you again we won't
necessarily know until the movie comes
out but i'm curious what you're all's
thoughts are on this i'm curious to see
if this is something that you all think
may actually be going on here but
regardless with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace